was hat die Ukraine aktuell wie in
diesem heftigen Kampf um avdevka
Russland noch
entgegenzusetzen nun also ich finde es
beeindruckend was ihr Reporte hier
berichtet hat und vielleicht möchte ich
den Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer mal hier
vermitteln nemen was es wirklich
bedeutet in einem artilleriekrieg
verwickelt zu sein bzw dort an der Front
zu sein und äh das
Artillerie Feuer permanent im zu hören
und vor allem auch exponiert zu sein äh
gegenüber e diesen Einschlägen und bzw
auch die ewige Furcht die man hat eben
dass man vielleicht getroffen wird es
ist ein schrecklich passives passives
Gefühl
eben russischen artillerieuer
ausgeliefert zu sein sei es jetzt
rohrartillerie oder raketenartillerie
und der psychologische Druck auf die
einzelnen Soldaten ist enorm und ich
kann ih nur persönliche Erfahrung sagen
wenn man dann wirklich meinen
befestigten Stellung ist in einem Bunker
fühlt es sich sehr erleichtern an wenn
man quasi unter der Erde liegt und
zumindest etwas Schutz hat und man geht
die ganze Zeit mit dem Gefühl umher das
kann man vielleicht vergleichen mit den
Sekunden bevor man einen Schlag ins
Gesicht erwartet ja also man ist
körperlich extremst angespannt und
denken Sie sich jetzt dass Soldaten hier
Monate Jahre lang schon also diesen
Druck ausgesetzt sind also was das
langfristig mit den Soldaten macht wage
ich hier gar nicht mehr vorzustellen um
jetzt auf Ihre Frage einzugehen auf die
jefka ja also hier ist das große Problem
selbstverständlich dass die Truppen in
der Stadt selbst früh oder später
vielleicht abgeschnitten werden können
bzw eben dass es zu einer Art Festung
auf diefk kommt eben wo die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte hier langsam ausgeblutet
werden wohl selbstverständig die Russen
wie bereits erwähnt große Verluste haben
mein persönlicher sorgnis oder warum ich
mir Sorgen mache was diese Entwicklung
betrifft ist nicht so sehr die Stadt
selbst sondern was kommt danach und ob
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte sich
hinter aftievka ja einkraben können bzw
hier relativ schnell jetzt eine neue
Verteidigungslinie hochziehen können
können bzw hier eben ein gestaffeltes
Verteidigungssystem etablieren das ist
enorm wichtig wenn auf die FK verloren
geht führt es zu einer Begradigung der
Front es wird jetzt kein unmittelbar
strategischen Einfluss haben auf das
Kampfgeschehen bzw
ähm wird es auch nicht so sein dass es
jetzt nennen ein nennenswerter Erfolg
wäre für die russischen Streitkräfte
zumindest wäre es ein sehr teuer
erkaufter Erfolg aber langfristig ist es
so eben die ist es wichtig dass die
Ukraine hier Verteidigungsstellungen
etabliert eben um die Stadt sollte sie
verloren gehen um den also die Einnahme
der Stadt den den den den russischen
Vormarsch hier etwas eindämmen zu können
es gibt aber auch andere Sektoren eben
wo die Russen großen Druck erhöhen z.B
im Bereich
kupjansk dort in der Gegend und hier ist
es auch so eben dass die Ukraine
wahrscheinlich sich es sch wer tut im
Moment Reserven zu verschieben es sind
nicht mehr genügend Reserven auch
vorhanden auf ukrainischer Seite und
Russland selbstverständlich kämpft hat
auch Personalprobleme das möchte ich ja
nicht klein ren aber beide Seiten wie
gesagt sind relativ erschöpft es gibt
aber größeren offensiven Druck im Moment
von Russland und das letzten Punkt
möchte ich vielleicht hier erwähnen
Russland in den nächsten Monaten hat mit
Sicherheit in drei Bereichen einen
Vorteil zumindest
was die Quantität betrifft erstens was
Artilleriemunition betrifft das ist sehr
signifikant weil es nach wie vor ein
Artillerie dominierter Krieg ist
zweitens was FPV Drohnen also
selbstgebaute kamikaz Drohnen betrifft
hier hat Russland einen Vorteil das ist
natürlich auch jetzt der relativ
m ja von Vorteil für das unmittelbare
Kampfgeschehen und drittens im Bereich
elektronische Kampfführung ist es hat
Russland hier einen Vorteil und
elektronische Kriegsführung also das
heißt jetzt Störsender und so weiter die
eben angreifende drohen ablenken können
bzw ähm die eben die Verbindung
unterbringen unterbrechen können eben
von Drohnen hier ist es natürlich so
dass je mehr drohen auf dem Schlachtfeld
eingesetzt werden desto wichtiger die
elektronische Kampfführung her ist und
ich glaube im Vergleich jetzt zu einen
meiner vorherigen frontbesuchen ist es
so dass ich am meisten das wahrgenommen
hat die Präsenz eben von diesen FBV
drohen die wirklich überall sind und die
ständig im Einsatz sind schauen wir mal
auf einen Bereich wir haben auch eine
Karte vorbereitet wo es für die
ukrainischen Truppen vorangegangen ist
wir schauen jetzt in die Region Cherson
denn dort sollen die ukrainischen
Truppen Brückenköpfe am nipro am Fluss
errichtet haben während also Russland
von Umgruppierung spricht aber klar da
gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche
narrative in diesem Krieg aber die große
Frage die das natürlich bedeutet wenn
dort die Truppen vorrücken und da kommt
nämlich eine Frage aus dem Stream dazu
was wie das einzuordnen ist was das
bedeuten könnte als Erfolg für die
Ukraine und zwar möchte Stefan warenberg
bei YouTube gerne wissen wie realistisch
ist es dass die Ukraine in der Region
Cherson ab dem kommenden Frühling bis
zur Krim sogar vordringen
kann also soweit kann ich jetzt die Lage
nicht voraussagen selbstverständlich ich
möchte ein paar Punkte erwähnen erstens
erfolgte dieser Vorstoß nachdem die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive bereits
kulminierte es gibt also keine
unterstützungsachse für offensive
Operationen im militärischen
in militärischen Unternehmungen braucht
man eine unter schützungsachse um eben
nicht
den Gegner dazu
veranlassen dass er eben seine Reserven
alle in diese eine Richtung eben wo im
dieser Brückenkopf jetzt entsteht
entsenden kann das ist also extrem
schwierig im Moment für du kinischen
Streitkräfte hier auszubrechen weil es
eben diese unterstützungsaktie nicht
gibt dann reden wir hier von kleineren
Gruppierungen ukrainischer Soldaten also
vielleicht mehreren hundert und
die auch jetzt dann nicht über das
notwendige Gerät für einen größeren
Durchbruch verfügen dann ist die
Versorgungslage im Winter natürlich eine
ganz andere die Anforderungen eben für
den Nachschub ein ganz anderer als im
Sommer dann sind die
Witterungsbedingungen eben Regen Schnee
und so weiter schwerenis den Soldaten
auch hier durchzuhalten also ich glaube
man muss realistisch sein was dieser
Vorstoß hierreichen kann es ist eine
limitierte Operation würde ich sagen die
jetzt da keinen großen strategischen
Einfluss auf das
Kriegsgeschehen bzw Frontverlauf in
unmittelbarer Zukunft eben unmittelbarer
Zukunft wird sie haben gerade die
Versorgung angesprochen können Sie das
uns noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter
aufzeigen was ein kalter Winter ein
frostiger winterschneestürme was das
auch alles für Auswirkung auf die
Versorgung haben
könnten nun die Witterungs Verhältnisse
haben Auswirkungen auf die Munition z.B
auf M die einzelnen gepanzerten
Fahrzeuge auf die Motoren m auf die
Erhaltung der Kampfkraft also ist es den
Soldaten warm haben die Soldaten genug
Öfen und so weiter
ähm ist es äh trocken genug in den
einzelnen Cremen ist es wirklich so eben
dass es den ganzen Winter über
überschneiden wird oder bleibt es eben
sehr nass hier gibt es verschiedenste
Faktoren und ähm ist es so dass es viel
bewölkt ist das limitiert dann auch den
Einsatz z.B von drohen auf beiden Seiten
und so weiter also hier gibt es dutzende
dutzende Faktoren die wichtig sind aber
ich möchte das immer jetzt wirklich im
Kontext wissen das heißt also die
Bedingungen sind ein Faktor aber sicher
nicht der entscheidende Faktor in diesem
Krieg und das hat auch ja das letzte
Jahr gezeigt sie dürfen nicht vergessen
dass die russischen Streitkräfte im
Winter in die Offensive übergegangen
sind und
dass auch die Ukraine relativ lange
angegriffen hat in dieser Gegenoffensive
wo schon die Schlammperiode
im begonnen hatte in der Ukraine und ich
war ja selbst an der Front während
dieser schlampmperiode und wenn man hier
wirklich mit
Rad Panzern bzw mit gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen mit Rädern und einzelnen
Fahrzeugen mit Rädern fährt und nicht
mit Ketten
man bleibt relativ schnell stecken also
es ist wirklich so eben das man versinkt
fast im Schlamm wenn die Straße nicht
asphaltiert ist also sollte es ein
wärmerer
Winter werden wie im letzten Jahr dann
hat das natürlich unmittelbaren Einfluss
auf die Angriffsoperationen beider
Seiten es gibt noch eine ja eine sehr
große Frage auf jeden Fall eine eine
Frage die in die Zukunft gerichtet ist
aus dem Stream die ich gerne zum Schluss
noch an Sie stellen möchte natürlich
interessiert das nämlich viele und zwar
stellt sich der User der sich Ike nennt
er oder sie die Frage wie schätzen Sie
die Wahscheinlichkeit ein dass 2024 das
letzte Kriegsjahr sein wird ich weiß es
ist schwer in die Glaskugel zu schauen
aber vielleicht können Sie für uns
zumindest meine Analyse Wagen was es
alles bräuchte für die eine Version und
was passiert in der in der zweiten
Version ich kann mich hier relativ kurz
halten also beide Seiten glauben noch
genügend militärische Optionen zu haben
es gibt auf russischer Seite kein
einziges indit dass äh der gremel bereit
wäre zu verhandeln auf ukrainischer
Seite glaube ich würde es durchaus äh ja
ähm einzelne Akteure geben die bereit W
zumindest Gespräche zu beginnen ja ob
sie dann wirklich
wirklich ehrlich verhandeln wollen sei
dahingestellt aber ich glaube beide
Seiten pochen noch auf militärische
Optionen um eben hier
äh vielleicht eine Wende im nächsten
Jahr
also zu erreichen aber ich glaube man
muss realistisch sein auf ukrainischer
Seite sollte das nächste Jahr zu einem
Aufbaujahr für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte genutzt werden das heißt
also eine defensivstrategie würde ich
hier wahrscheinlich vorziehen um eben
die Kampfkraft zu erhalten bzw die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte aufzubauen
gleichzeitig muss man aber den Druck auf
die russischen Streitkräfte
aufrechterhalten weil wie man mit
afjevka auch sieht wenn man zu ser der
Druck nachläst dann geht
gehen die russischen Truppen auch
schnell wieder in die Offensive über und
ich glaube das Ziel auf russischer Seite
ist nach wie vor in unmittelbarer
Zukunft
gesamten donbas also die oblasten donetk
und lohansk unter voller russischer
Kontrolle zu bringen langfristig glaube
ich dennoch dass das Ziel des kremels
Vladimir Putins nach wie vor ist die
gesamte Ukraine zu unterjochen das heißt
eine prorussische Regierung dort zu
etablieren und ich glaube von russischer
Perspektive sieht man keinen Grund eben
diesen Krieg frühzeitig hier abzubrechen
sie glauben eben dass langfristig es von
Vorteil ist den Krieg auszudehnen so
lang wie nur möglich und auf
ukrainischer Seite ist glaube ich das
große Problem wenn man auf militärischer
Seite sagt wir gehen in die Defensive
könnte es hier vielleicht zu Spannungen
auf der mit der politischen Ebene eben
geben ja weil die politische Ebene
selbstverständlich auch Erfolge
vorweisen will und das hat mir auch
öffentlich ein bisschen gesehen dass es
auf ukrainischer Seite hier intern
einige span gab aber ich glaube das
Wichtigste zu verstehen ist das Jahr
2024 muss ein Aufbaujahr werden für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte und die
Ukraine würde gut tun in die Defensive
zu gehen obwohl e gleichzeitig der Druck
aufrechterhalten bleiben sollte auf die
russischen Streitkräfte aber das muss
nicht unmittelbar eine neue Offensive
bedeuten die Ukraine hat auch nicht die
nötige notwendige Munition nochmals eine
offensive durchzuführen wie sie es jetzt
mit der Gegenoffensive im Sommer und
Herbst getan hat das muss man auch offen
sagen es gibt hier einen Nachteil was
die Artilleriemunition betrifft aber
gleichzeitig gibt es sehr viele neue
indigene Systeme Langstrecken Drohnen
die eben benutzt werden um tiefe also
anziiele in der Tiefe des russischen
Raums des russisch besetzten Gebietes
anzugreifen und sich auch früher oder
später eben stärker und stärker auf die
Krim zu konzentrieren und hier kann ich
mir gut vorstellen dass früh oder später
eben einzelne Brücken verstärkt
angegriffen werden einzelne
Militärstützpunkte und so weiter und man
wird nach wie vor versuchen den Druck
auf die Krim aufrecht zu erhalten um e
den Druck dadurch auf die russische
militärische und politische Führung
sukzessive im Jahr 2024 zu erhöhen und
die munitionssituation auf ukrainischer
Seite wird sich wahrscheinlich
verbessern auch Ende des Jahres was ein
weiterer Punkt werde wäre warum die
Ukraine auch nicht jetzt so so schnell
glaub äh also wahrscheinlich diesen
Krieg beenden wird